في هذا المكان تحديدا تم اغتيال وتصفيه
احد قاده كتيبه جبع وهو مجدي فشافشه 37
عاما هنا بدات الصوره حيث قام الاحتلال
والوحدات الخاصه الاسرائيليه بمحصر هذا
المكان ومن ثم اغتياله على الفور من خروجه
او اثناء خروجه من المنزل هنا احد شهود
العيان واحد
اقارب الشهيد تتحدث لنا حول تفاصيل ما جرى
بدايه عظم الله اجركم ما الذي جرى اثناء
محاصره الاحتلال والوحدات الخاصه للمنزل
الله يرحمه هم حاصروا المنزل كان الله
يرحمه مجدي ياكل طلع روح طلب من مرته اكل
قالها قالت له مرته انا عامل لخنه قال لها
لا جاي على بالي فرض الجبنه قعد ياكل يعني
بكل شافهم على القمرات قال لها هي اج
الجيش حط سلاح هون رفع ايديه وقاموا طخو
يعني لا قاوم ولا عمل اي
شيء وصى على مره مت وصى على ابنه الله
يرحمه وبنته عنده ولد وبنت عظم الله اجركم
اذا يعني جرائم الاحتلال متواصله حيث ايضا
في نفس الوقت تم
اغتيال ثلاثه او اصابه ثلاثه فلسطينيين تم
نقلهم الى المستشفى فيما اعتقل الاحتلال
ثلاثه فلسطينيين من بينهم اثنين من
المطاردين ووالد احد المطاردين تم
اعتقالهم ونقلهم الى مراكز التحقيق من مد
من بلده جبع جنوب محافظه جنين ليث جعار
الجزيره